[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم فضيحه بالصوت والصوره وثقها
تحقيق لشبكه الجزيره عن اساليب تستخدمها
اسرائيل للتاثير على الحياه السياسيه
البريطانيه بل واستهداف الساسه المعارضين
لمصالحها من خلال ممارسات تبلغ حد التظليل
واغتيال الشخصيه ففي الدوله التي صدر منها
وعد بلفور الذي قامت على اساسه دوله
اسرائيل يتفاخر موظف في السفاره
الاسرائيليه بالقدره على الاطاحه بوزير في
الحكومه البريطانيه ردا على مواقفه
المعارضه لسياسه الاستيطان الاسرائيليه
فضيحه بدات تداعياتها تتكشف في بريطانيا
عبر مطالبات نواب في مجلس العموم بالتحقيق
في القضيه فيما سارعت اسرائيل لاحتوائها
عبر التقليل من اهميه الموظف الذي صدرت
عنه التصريحات تقرير عزيز
المرنيسي فضيحه بالصوت والصوره عنوانها
الابرز التغلغل الصهيوني في الاوساط
السياسيه البريطانيه شهادات موثقه ضمن
تسجيلات سر هي ثمره عمل دؤوب لوحده
التحقيقات في شبكه الجزيره استغرق سته
اشهر ومن بين ما تكشف عنه التسجيلات
محاولات دبلوماسي اسرائيلي اسقاط ساسه
بريطانيين مناهضين للاستيطان الاسرائيلي
في فلسطين المحتله ويظهر الدبلوماسي
الاسرائيلي داخل احد مطاعم لندن وهو يتبجح
بقدرته على الاطاحه بوزراء من حزب
المحافظين الحاكم بل يعبر عن رغبته في ان
يطيح بوزير الدوله في الخارجيه البريطانيه
سير الن دنكن المعروف بانتقاده اللاذع
للاستيطان في الضفه الغربيه وبنسبه للموظف
الاسرائيلي فان سير الن مصدر للمشكلات
كما وصف وزير الخارجيه بورس جونسون بانه
مغفل بسبب انهماكه في قضايا ثانويه تجعله
غير فعال في دعمه لاسرائيل كما تتضمن
التسجيلات التي تكشف كيف يمتد النفوذ
الاسرائيلي ليصل الى مستويات عليا داخل
حزب المحافظين الحاكم في بريطانيا محادثه
تصف فيها مساعده وزير اخر من المحافظين هو
روبرت هالفن كيف استخدمت موقعها الوظيفي
لتقنع بعض نواب البرلمان بتوجيه اسئله الى
رئيسه الوزراء تريز ماي بهدف الحصول على
تاييدها لاسرائيل
وهو التاييد الذي عبرت عنه ماي في
انتقادها الاخير لخطاب وزير الخارجيه الام
ريكي جون كيري الذي تناول فيه قضيه
الاستيطان
الاسرائيلي مواقف تعري نفوذ اسرائيل داخل
حزبي المحافظين والعمال في بريطانيا عبر
سفارتها في لندن بتقديم الدعم السري
والمال الذي يسعى المحافظون للحصول عليه
من المانحين المؤيدين لاسرائيل ولو كان
ذلك على حساب التخلي عن مبادئ السياسه
الخارجيه للحكومه
البريطانيه وفي رد فعل مباشر على تحقيق
الجزيره قدمت ده الوزير البريطاني
استقالتها واع تظر سفير اسرائيل في لندن
مارك ريغف اما وصفها بتصريحات غير مقبوله
تماما من موظف صغير لا يمثل موقف الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في الاثناء تعالت اصوات من
نواب المحافظين وعمالين مطالبه بتحقيق
كامل ومفصل فيما وصف بالتدخل السافر وال
مستهجن لممثل دوله اجنبيه في العمليه
السياسيه
البريطانيه تدخل ما فتئ تمارسه ايضا
منظمات غير يهوديه داعمه لاسرائيل ومنها
مجموعات اصدقاء اسرائيل الحزبيه في
البرلمان البريطاني من خلال توظيف اساليب
وادوات ضغط متنوعه على الافراد والمؤسسات
منها الناعم ومنها الخشن حفاظا على زخم
الدعم البريطاني لاسرائيل
ينضم الينا من القدس الباحث والصحفي
الاسرائيلي الحنان ميلر ومن لندن
البروفيسور طوني ترافيس استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه لندن اهلا بضيفي
الكريمين بروفيسور تراز الا يرقى ما تم
تسريبه في هذا الجزء من التحقيق الى مرتبه
المس بالامن القومي
لبريطانيا ان نصف بتهديد للامن القومي
البريطاني وكنها مفاجاه
كبرى للكثير من الناس في الحكومه وفي
الاوساط
الدبلوماسيه دبلوماسيون الذين يعملون
للسفارات في لندن والمدن الكبرى الاخرى
يحاولون التاثير في النقاش في البلد ما
يحدث هو
ان دبلوماسي بطريقه غير دبلوماسيه يتحدث
عن مساعده وزير
الخارجيه بطريقه كما قلنا غير دبلوماسيه
ولا اعتقد ان اليس
مفاجئا ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه تحاول ان
تؤثر لكن الطريقه التي تم بها ذلك بطريقه
مباشره عبر هذا الشخص ليس مسا بالامن
القومي البريطاني لانه كان من دوله
كاسرائيل ماذا لو كان نفس الفعل من دوله
اخرى ولنقل روسيا على سبيل
المثال
اعتقد ان هذا سؤال جيد الطريقه التي ترى
بها المملكه المتحده اسرائيل مختلفه عن عن
رؤيتها
لروسيا من وجهه
النظر
بريطانيه اسرائيل تعتبر شريكا
مقربا
وبريطانيا صوتت مع
اعضاء مجلس الامن ضد اسرائيل وقد اعتبر
ذلك ليس عملا يعكس الصداقه اذا هناك توتر
في العلاقات بالرغم انه في معظم الاحيان
المملكه المتحده كان لها علاقات جيده مع
اسرائيل سيد الحنان ميلر الخارجيه
الاسرائيليه وصفت ما تم تسريبه بانه جاء
من موظف بسيط ولكن ما يثبته التحقيق يتكلم
عن شبكات واسعه طال مسؤولين عديدين في
الحزبين في بريطانيا العمال وكذلك
المحافظين والسياسيين بل وحتى منظمات
طلابيه واكاديمي اذا المساله اوسع من مجرد
تصريح لموظف وصفته السفاره بانه بسيط وان
لم يكن بسيطا حسب ما شاهدنا في هذا
المقطع نعم اسرائيل تعمل علنا من اجل كسب
الدعم في البرلمان البريطاني عن طريق
مجموعات دعم اصدقاء اسرائيل في الحزب
المحافظ وفي حزب العمل وهذا ليس سرا و حتى
في الجامعات هناك مجموعات داعمه لاسرائيل
وهذا مكشوف وعلني
ولكن التعليقات او تصريحات الموظف الصغير
ليست لائقه وبكل تاكيد الخارجيه الاسرائ
الاسرائيليه تعيد النظر في مثل هذا
التوظيف لناس ليسوا
بدبلوماسية عن مال وليس عن تاثير متداول
وهو معروف بين
الدول انا لم ارى التهديد يعني هذا الشخص
ليس بمرتبه التهديد هو ليس دبلوماسيا ولو
كان الامر مختلف ولو كان دبلوماسي في طاقم
السفاره لكان الامر مختلف ولكن السفاره
اعتذرت عن الموضوع
اقاله الموظف او الشخص هذا واعتقد ان
بريطان والخارجيه البريطانيه قابله
الاعتذار والقصه
انتهت حتى حتى الان على الاقل هناك توتر
كما تطرق السيد ل القصه انتهت سيد ميلر
القصه انتهت حتى مع مطالبه برلمانيين من
الحزبين المحافظين وكذلك العمال بفتح
تحقيق معمق فيما وصفه بانه قد يرقى الى
مساله المس بالامن في
بريطانيا
مثل هذه التعبيرات يعني الامن القومي يعني
مبالغه وتضخيم للموضوع سنرى في الايام
القلي القادمه هل فعلا يعني تتكبر القصه
ولكن باعتقادي يعني مع الحرج والارباك
الذي سبب الموضوع لاسرائيل وللخارج
القصه يعني ليست بهذه قد يعني بهذه
المرتبه من من الاهميه حتى ما حتى الان
حسب ما شهدنا
سيد بروفيسور ترافيس هل توافق ضيفي عندما
يقول بان المساله بسيطه والتاثير معروف
وعلني فيما يتعلق بما تقوم به اسرائيل لدى
الاوساط السياسيه وكذلك الفاعله في
بريطانيا وان ما تم نشره اقل من عادي هل
برايك هذا
صحيح اعتقد انه من المفهوم ان حكومه
اسرايل وليس فقط هذهه الحكومه تحاول ان
تؤثر في الطريقه التي يتعامل بها
السياسيون في المملكه المتحده وبهذه
المناسبه
الطريقه التي تحدث
بها الموظف في سفاره اسرائيل هي الطريقه
التي يتحدث بها
الدبلوماسيون كونه دبلوماسيين لست متاكدا
من ذلك في
هذه المناسبه عدد من اعضاء البرلمان سوف
يثيرون هذا الامر لكن لا اعتقد ان الحكومه
بشكل عام حزب
المحافظين هو صديق لاسرائيل ولا اعتقد انه
سيدخله الملاحظات ويكررون سيد الحنان منر
فيما يتعلق ب صلب الاشكال والذي كان سببا
فيما قاله هذا الموظف في داخل السفاره
الاسرائيليه في بريطانيا موضوع الاستيطان
الا يوحي ما تم تسريبه بان اسرائيل في
حاله اشكاليه فيما يتعلق بتسويق الاستيطان
حتى لدى حلفائها لتل لمثل هذه
الاساليب لا شك ان هناك خلاف عميق بين
حكومات الدول الغربيه اليوم حتى اليمينيه
منها مثل حكومه بريطانيا اليمنيه وبين
موقف اسرائيل حول الاستيطان يعنيان هذا
الموضوع اسرائيل منعزله فيه اي و ليس هناك
دعم اوروبي او غربي لموضوع الاستيطان ولكن
الاساليب هذه لا اعتقد انها استثنائيه
يعني هذه محادثه او مكالمه بين اثنين في
مطعم هناك لندن عاصمه هامه في اوروبا
وهناك لوبي او يعني مجموعات ضغط سعوديه
وعربيه وسوريه وايرانيه يعني هناك كل
اشكال الضغط وال واللوبي في في في لندن
وفي غيرها من عواصم اوروبا فبالتالي يعني
هذه ليس محادثه استثنائيه باعتقادي بين
موظفين صغار في في السفرات ا موظف صغير
ويملك كل هذه العلاقات ويتكلم بهذه
الطريقه بالمناسبه برايك هل سيتم معاقبه
هذا الموظف وما شكل العقاب وان لم يعاقب
لماذا السفاره اعلنت انه سيقال من منصبه
فورا او قيل من منصبه
هذا السهل لانه حسب ما قالت السفاره هو
ليس من طاقم الطاقم الدبلوماسي للسفاره
اسرائيل في كل عواصم او في كل السفرات في
العالم توظف ناس محليين او اسرائيليين
ليسوا من تاقم الدبلوماسي ان كان فعل شيئا
عاديا سيد الحنان مر ان كان فعل شيئا
عاديا اذا لماذا
يقال لانه هذا اربك السفاره الاسرائيليه
هو تكلم بشكل غير لائق وغير الدبلوماسي
واحرج اسرائيل واحرج الخارجيه الاسرائيليه
ام يعني بكل تاكيد حتى ناس صغار موظفين
صغار ليسوا دبلوماسيين ينبغي ان يتكلموا
ويتصرفوا بشكل لائق
ودبلوماسي و لا يتكلمون عن حتى في لقاء
خاصه في لقاء مفتوح ومع الناس خارج
السفارات مثل ما كان الصحفي في الجزيره
يعني تكلم بشكل غير
لائق يعني اخطا في الموضوع ولازم يدفع
الثمن للخطا سيد ترافيس هل تعتقد بان
الموضوع سيتم احتوائه كما يتوقع ضيفي من
القدس ام
سيتفاعل تكون مفاجاه لو ارادت الحكومه
البريطانيه ان
تمضي قدما في هذه المساله اعتقد ان هناك
شخصيات مهمه لكن ربما الناس يقولون اشياء
كثيره تختلف عن ما يقولونه في المواقف
العامه هل هو دبلوماسي ام لا او شخص يمثل
الحكومه
الاسرائيليه يتحدث ويتم تسجيله
كلامه وهذا دليل
اخر على انه ينبغي
ليس هناك نقاشات خاصه الان لم يعد هناك
سيد ملر هل برايك تقبل السفاره
الاسرائيليه في لندن في حال وجود ضغط من
جهات فاعله في داخل بريطانيا بان يفتح
التحقيق ل متابعه ما جرى وما تم
بثه السفاره بكل تاكيد تحاول ان تحتوي
الموضوع باسرع ما يمكن الصفير ريجف اعتذر
لوزير داكن واعتذر فح
تحقيق حسب ما فهمته يعني الموضوع يعني
انتهى باعتذار اسرائيل وقبول بريطانيا
للاعتذار فلا ارى يعني ضروره للتحقيق
واتفاجئ لو كان هناك تحقيق جديد غر مطالبه
بعض البرلمانيين البريطانيين المعادين
لاسرائيل بالتحقيق وهذه المطالبه بكل
تاكيد ستتم ولكن اعتقد ان الغالبيه في
البرلمان
والحكومه والحزب الحاكم المحافظ المقارب
من اسرائيل يعني تحتوي الموضوع ولا تريد
ان تضخمه اكثر مما هو كنت معنا من القدس
الباحث والصحفي الاسرائيلي الحنان ميلر
واشكرا جزيلا لك وكذلك ضيفي من لندن
البروفيسور توني ترافيس استاذ العلوم
السيا في جامعه لندن شكرا جزيلا لك في
الملف الثاني من الحصاد يناقش حسن جمول
وفاه هاشمي رفسنجاني رئيس مجلس تشخيص
مصلحه النظام في ايران وتداعياتها على
المشهد السياسي الايراني